[Music]
i'm having a great time here in chicago
i love it one big reason are incredible
audiences you people have been amazing
now
i don't just talk
i deliver
to show my appreciation i've decided to
give something back one lucky audience
member tonight will be personally
serenaded right now by the one and only
michael buble that's right
right this is of great honor recording
star sex symbol michael buble
this is really exciting stuff when does
this ever happen
and the winner
is in seat
h413
hh413 we have hh
it's this woman right here
she has no idea she's looking the wrong
way
it's hell come on up yes
yes
come on up here
that's all right take your time
personally serenaded
hi
how are you
right this way this is a
what is your name
nicole this is nicole and where are you
from nicole uh michigan but i live in
chicago okay this is very nice from
michigan but you live in chicago all
right what's that
okay this is awkward i'm being told
right now that michael buble could not
make it this evening
i'm really sorry we do have a
replacement
okay and your name again one last time
nicole nicole will now be serenaded by
aziz ansari aziz
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
my name is aziz ansari
and
it's come to my attention
there's a very special
young lady here tonight
look at this beautiful caucasian skin
and damage he's got close to
i think there's only one thing left to
tell you
and that is
[Music]
my whole life has changed
since you came in
i knew back then you were that special
one
i'm so in love
so deep in love
you open me i'm wide open
and i'm doing things i never do
but i feel so good i feel so good
why'd it take so long me finding you
my whole life has changed
[Applause]
my whole life has changed
my whole life has changed
a season sorry ladies and gentlemen